thank you for joining us i'm john
langler and we do start with breaking
news in the northeast valley one driver
is dead after a three vehicle crash this
happened at the intersection of lake
mead and walnut bianca holman is live
there right now at the scene streets
there still closed right now bianca
good morning good afternoon john so yeah
we are here at this intersection and you
can see still police presence out here
they've actually moved one of the
vehicles that was involved in the crash
and so again a little bit more about the
situation that happened this morning
we're told by police that three vehicles
were involved this morning at the crash
that happened at 7 a.m a white car a red
car and a box truck one person died on
the scene police investigated the scene
all morning long trying to determine
what happened details still limited at
this time we know that again once we
have more information we will keep you
updated online and here on air and again
you can see that the intersection here
at lake mead and walnut are still closed
so again if you're heading this
direction please use caution reporting
live from lake mead and walnut bianca
holman 8 news now
all right bianca thank you very much